>> Hi. I'm here today at Google IO with Mike
from E! Entertainment. Mike, you want to introduce
yourself and tell us a little bit about E!
Entertainment and what you've done or built
for Android.
>> WAGHALTER: Sure. I'm Mike Waghalter. I'm
director of business development and digital
media for E! And E! is the world's largest
provider of entertainment information and
content through our cable network, which is
available in over 95 million homes in the
U.S. And we pride great programming, like
E! News, topical entertainment content as
well as reality shows like Girls Next Door
and Keeping Up with the Kardashians, Kendra,
our new show, which is premiering June 7th,
and, you know, we also have great shows like
The Soup and Chelsea Lately, more comedy shows,
topical comedy shows. We also have a 24/7
source for entertainment news and content
online, eonline at eonline.com. And for Android,
we've basically taken our Web property, eonline,
and taken all the great content, the rich
media content, everything from video clips
from our shows to original topical video content
property, hyper plug-in news now, which is
really a 24/7, everything entertainment news
as it's happening. We produce professional
video segments about each story as it happens
throughout the day, tapping into the resources
of E! News to do so. So, we have all that
great content and including hundreds and hundreds
of the latest photos of your favorite celebrities
as well as the team move, an editorial team
that's writing, covering the world of entertainment
in Hollywood, writing stories throughout the
day and updating to the site. We've taken
all that great content and made it into a
mobile application for Android that takes
into account the unique and mobile environment,
the smaller form factor, but also the fact
that it's always on your device so making
sure that as we're updating your real time
on our site, those updates are reflected on
the mobile application as well.
>> So can you tell us maybe what led you to
build something for Android, at particular,
the technical aspects of it, user interface
features?
>> WAGHALTER: Sure. Actually, I can tell you
we've been into the mobile space since 2002,
starting with a mobile WAP site or a mobile
web now, and one of the reasons, I think,
that we so readily embraced Android was because
of its ability to handle both the slick user
interface and the interaction so intuitive
for a user. I mean, it's really designed for
anyone, from a 7-year-old to 7-year-old can
easily figure it out without looking through
a complex manual, which really hindered a
lot of application development and just any
kind of presentation of rich media on mobile
devices in the past. That was one of the first
things we liked about Android. We want, you
know, we're very brand conscious today, so
we want to make sure that anything we put
the E! brand on represents the brand well,
and is slick and flashy. Obviously, the world
of entertainment in Hollywood is very flashy.
So we really wanted to put something together
that, for example, showed a high res full
screen photos that we have, you know, that
has a very slick loading, fast loading video
player, which we have with our Android app,
free online. And then the second big factor
was because it's an open source platform,
really the growth potential of the platform
is limitless, and we're already seeing multiple
OEMs embracing it, building handsets. I think
we're going to see multiple U.S. carriers.
It started to ring out on T-Mobile. I suspect--without
having any kind of inside information--I suspect
we're going to see more carriers embrace it
as well. So I think it provides a great opportunity
for us to get increased distribution for our
content and our brand.
>> That's great.
>> WAGHALTER: Yeah.
>> Are there any particular features of the
platform? Because it's an open platform, because
you can maybe access in the line of hardware,
are there things you can do on Android that
you might not be able to do on other similar
mobile devices?
>> WAGHALTER: Sure. I mean, one of the things
that really makes the mobile environment from
the typical PC environment is that your connection
speed can vary depending on your location,
depending on the number of other mobile customers
that are hitting a particular local tower
that, you know--so we want to be able to build
an app that can monitor network conditions,
and particularly for video, for serving rich
media like video, be able to serve the cleanest
video possible based on both network availability
and the particular method of access at the
moment. So whether or not you're using your
Android handset via WiFi, via 3G or 2.5G,
we can serve up a different video that's a
seamless experience to the end user, but that
has the highest quality that the network allows
at that moment.
>> Okay. That's great.
>> WAGHALTER: Yeah.
>> Well, thank you for coming out and talking
to us.
>> WAGHALTER: Okay. Thanks for having us.
>> All right.
>> WAGHALTER: Okay, thanks.